with their red bricks pipes and
electrical equipment abandoned
industrial buildings exude a certain
charm that combines well with culture
and art
art we'll play a central role in the
former Kindle brewery in Berlin's nguoi
cone district opened in 1872 beer was
brewed here until 2005 now the complex
is being remodeled aundrea speedla of
switzerland is in charge of the project
its surface of about 5,500 square meters
will house artists studios and be a
venue for events value in parallel I
plan to have three exhibitions in
parallel I want to have a site-specific
showing in a boiler building a space 20
meters high it's fun to meet the
hallways and then along with that a
monographic and a thematic exhibition
that it came out the shower she knew the
mash house with what was once Europe's
largest brewing coppers will be
preserved to accentuate the architecture
andreia speedla has clear ideas of what
it will look like when finished as I
here in I don't want to place art and
focus here in the mash house it will be
a cafe but I can imagine installing
video works in one of the coppers on me
I need people would have to look in
through the hatch to see them that I
enjoy with us to see this former
crematorium in Berlin's vetting district
is another example after 90 years of
operation it was shut down in 2001
this year a gallery dedicated to the
work of young artists was opened in the
former Chapel
it is currently showing work by the
German Norwegian video artists young
mehlhorn
it is may be unconcerned yet every
medium functions in these spaces and
it's on whether it's a sound
installation a video installation or a
sculpture even oil paintings work in the
smaller spaces or the large one we're in
right now this was once home to the
motor pool of former East German leader
a leash hanukkah today the fog lights
shunt which means motor pool is a
factory courtyard culture venue and home
to about a dozen artists studios and
lots of East German history like this
bar with its original furnishings the
former canteen is currently showing the
hull book collection in the exhibition
bald eagle Michelle Munoz graphic arts
print shop has moved in next door into
what was once the cafeteria kitchen for
the motor pool his artist clients
include internationally famous artists
Marilla was one of the first to move on
to these grounds the millions of the
guns fantastic if you look like this is
a fantastic location for me couche it's
alibi'd and i love the idea of working
in a kitchen he is also opt because what
I do is it kind of cooking cooking with
lots of passion to create a dish and in
this case the dish his art isn't
employed on flight even kunst back to
the kindle brewery the art venue will
open in the fall of 2014
shoot'em univ engine does the sun i
would like to see this become a vibrant
venue for the noi con districts here in
the neighborhood with the cafe and
various events and of course we'll have
exhibitions of international
contemporary art in the center of
shaluinn internet another gig in watts
cranston the kindle brewery is one of
many examples in berlin where art has
come alive amidst former industrial
architecture